[Applause] [Music] rosik for the Blue Jackets
failed to clear Carlson snapshot on the way kicked
out rebound scolling kick out save by Ms leans was
Dynamite on KET off identity and game right off
the GetGo great shot from the point kicked away
the follow-up right side of the screen there's
ketoff and what a split save there by m leakin
catch it with the right pad visiting Columbus
in the white sweaters one for one on the PK rosic
moves it along to Bean Bean lets it Go Shrugged
that there by lingren mantha at the attacking
line lost it on the back check there's fan Tilly
the 19-year-old roaring back ahead and until
he fires stick save lingren put it out of play
G Branson bstrm then down the wing chikov roaring
in to the front to scrolling Lind a dynamite save
there genov reloads and fires just missed it on
the short side carali and Danforth with texier
a fourth line unit for the Blue Jackets off The
Intercept Wilson's in alone Tom Wilson to his back
hand he was bothered shot could be a penalty shot
and it is for Tom Wilson tried to High play turned
it over Wilson on the break away looking to put
Washington on top Wilson snakes his way in off the
deep Le at the end of the line he stayed with them
there work it around at the point farari fires
easy stop there for M lein and he angled it into
the safety netting chipped along the wall Ganson
taking space away from Milano they fight for it
you have a peak down the Dasher singer right up
the gut fires glove save Linden and he'll hang on
and at least a grappling around the neck here's
that play still in JG just wheeling in there and
letting her fly great glove save didn't control
it and cylinder kept whacking at his glove there
to try to knock it the puck is free here and then
in front of the net a lot of traffic and bemstrom
tries to hammer it past the Cap's net Miner John
Carlson in tight quarters with Wilson this will
trickle back to Center Jenner regains Moon Jenner
had a hattrick earlier this season warnky fires
that's broken up front Buck 34 here in this hockey
game and lost so that means they have to shuffle
the deck when it comes to defense Oshi pressured
by baronov send it back marchenko curling drag
and snared out of the air off of alexv by lingren
rosik sent it down low sandine captures quickly
Rasmus sandine full blast through Center sandine
on the go tried to split the Defenders
Wilson there to help his Drive score Tom
[Applause] [Music]
Wilson rosic look at 96 skate away there
now the Caps are in attack mode he goes
hard between three guys Tom follows up and
there it is ricocheting off the left shoulder
and catching mitt exactly where you want to put
the puck probably didn't mean to shoot it there
at the Crux of the shoulder and the catching
glove but tomall Wilson on a rolling didn't
score but he did score on that last Chip Shot
chenko closing in fires lingren made the save
on that sharp shooter off the wing Kel marchenko
can he ever shoot the Bell that's a quick release
a very tough stop for any Go Johnny GD feed
it inside lingren a spectacular stop on Jenner
lingren again waving that right-handed catching
glove at the puck McMichael with a short-handed
Dash McMichael from the angle no troubles former
leans lost to year Blue Jackets failed to clear
Jansen then Keta switch the point of attack
Sande Jensen back door wide open Score Sunny
Milano put three passes together here's
the passing play just beautiful ring
quiet and then on the money to Milano he
froze a defenseman Did Jensen he froze a
goenda stick check at the line marchenko a man
who idolized Washington's great eight in front
there that one bounced around Swept Away by
stro marchenko in the high slot fires and
scores ROV was setting a screen in front of
may have gotten a deflection on that too and
just shoot the puck at all times and in front
of the net another big fella watch that little
might have got a little deflection on a Rolling
Puck and we'll wait and see who they give credit
to that goal buddy marchenko and baronov this
shot from marchenko baronov cruising in front
it tickles the twine barari from Deep then Alexia
fires stick save mer leens G Branson didn't get
it out Alexia to the front Phillips is there
denied by a sprawling M leans the puck beneath
him long enough for the whistle defensively
quality opportunities for this Trio working
D to D and look at the commotion in front the
coach says we want more havoc in front of the
net well that's a lot of havoc and it leads to a
wide open passing play to Phillips who just can't
put it underneath of the Fallen net minder a good
look from behind this is what Phillips is seeing
warky with help from Danforth and carali working
through Center uh-oh working in protest fires
great save by m leakin pressure comes from
Ganson Carlson now oetkin another seam pass
to KET up look away down low at the goal line
great save M linol has it long enough for the
whistles that opens up other thing look at
number eight lensky all he's focused on is
the other number eight there's the pass across
kudos to the goal tender to catch a piece of
that before it got cleanly to Tom Wilson and
there's the bounce off the body and the gobble
up with a blocker and that right arm playing
off the post in a diving M leans to cover drop
it on back for Ros levik's entry 7 Seconds
to go warnky this way Jenner Jenner fires
good save there for lingren nearly at the final
horn the caps will hold that one-goal lead after
two from Center keeps it on the window that'll
keep lingren in between the pipes bounce loose
to McMichael he'll stash it along now the headman
sends in oetkin he fires stop by m Le beautiful
play in the neutral zone McMichael chips it to
Mana mantha to Obie and tries to go top shelf
off the left shoulder and arm of M lein good
opportunity for the captain 's Captain being
hacked a little bit by Bean coming back there on
that play trying to hustle to get a piece of them
first lak has made 21 stops at least a handful
of them have been fabulous there's another off
the draw oetkin on that set piece trying to ring
just underneath the crossbar for those of you who
haven't been with us throughout T van reik injured
early in the first period the Caps have been
playing Five Defenders since centering pass right
up the gut here fr falling lingren outstanding
with a catching glove yeah hockey card save there
on the youngster he'll need to choose something
other than glove side [Music] [Applause] wow Point
position Severson finds his man tremendous save by
lingren here you'll take a look at it left side of
the screen marenko is going to be wide open he's
going to stop come out here he catches it tries
to get it up didn't get it up and the recovery
and the compete level of lingren Joe enough to
thwart their arguably their best chance 7 and 42 2
minutes each for ruffing two seconds to go the Cs
do the job on the backboards great work by Carlson
this one's done in the books two1 for the capitals
great sacrifices by the guys in red tonight